[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there is how's it going everyone it's a
wonderful Friday and we're here playing
more Pokemon taking you guys on we've
got our Pokemon experts here it's Callie
and Jake I'm not I'm not the Pokemon
expert at least Pokemon I'm here for the
ride though she's definitely like the
Pokemon master but I feel like you're
you're definitely up in there as well
like you're you guys both have a very
good handle on Pokemon and we're taking
you guys on today John there's gonna be
here in a second he's also switching
while he's doing everything but here he
is but yeah let's uh let's get into this
let's yeah let's do the thing I'm
excited to learn some about some real
good competitive Pokemon okay I'll learn
it from you I'll learn it from them well
anyone who's going this thing it's okay
we've got new technology on deck it's
now always testing something new out so
one think you mind to jean-luc that I
just remembered is when you're switching
you're gonna have to switch what when
you're picking moves right because you
guys go to link battle and then we'll
put in the code zero two seven nine I
think is what Gentiles put there and
then I want to select like ranked battle
rules and I'm using a rental team the
rental team is by I will talk about the
rental team while we're fixing the
display Luke career Peavy on Twitter who
is a VGC player
it's called goth control so it features
Gotha tell using the ability shadow tag
which pokemon can't switch out unless
they're ghost types and it also just
features some of my favorite Pokemon the
team is Gotha tell durant melodic
Tyranitar arcanine and sylveon so I'm
very excited I was laddering with this
team 10
mixed results because I'm still getting
used to the team but I'm really enjoying
it so yeah I will just go ahead and put
in the link code for double battle zero
two seven nine again yeah and I'm not
gonna bother switching out of the moves
cuz I think there's enough of a delay
and also I don't care do trust every the
honor system yeah I am gonna be
monitoring the chat by the way oh and
then if there are problems with
connectivity or something we might do
some raids I have a toxicity right
behind me check to have two max it's
right next to you oh wow I'm on point
today but I could also just be laddering
I mean I decided myself just because I
forget what the rules are called so I I
think we're gonna do ranked battle
series um let's see what do I want to do
I'll do ring pedal series too so that's
what we're going to be doing yeah this
is gonna be like the usual rules I'm
gonna select goth control that's what
I'm gonna do I also have some other
teams I might rotate - weezing zap which
I really wanted to use wheezing and then
a stage in Parks team from the world
champion Invitational I also have been
using but I struggle a lot against
Charizard
and torkoal teams and hard trick room
teams so that's why I really like the
goth Attell team oh yeah like the goth
control always makes me think of this is
goth control - I love it
baby Yoda says a nerd fest alert hey you
know what it is
okay thanks baby Yoda okay can you were
a cool guy baby Yoda Errol says hello
friends hello Erin how's it going we say
our first challenger Edward I like a lot
of the Pokemon they've got lined up
Brennan says hello gamespot hope
everyone's having a good Friday so far
it's getting there yeah we'll see how
this goes Mike I think a big challenge
for me is picking which Pokemon I want
to bring you got this
this is the first one day - that's a
very good card very good I like that
effect I had that on my last card I
updated to the curry card though because
I like Japanese Curtis I didn't mean it
as a thing oh oh thanks baby Yoda I'm
sorry that I jumped to a conclusion I'm
glad that we're all here to be friends
Brennan says great podcast by the way
thank you very much every community
Fridays Brennan pops in to say yeah
really we really appreciate it
yeah least I appreciate it I'm not here
every week but I wonder what the frost
lasses role is gonna be
like frost last a lot it isn't frost
last one of those Pokemon it's got like
a pretty dark background or am I
thinking by the way if you're fighting
and you're in the chat say hi yeah no
unless I'm just matching with random
people but I hope Edward that you're
watching and that you're not maxing out
your timer on the honor system here at
community Friday's so I just noticed
that you've got your character has one
of those yuccas jackets on yeah that's
real good I bet that this oh okay
Duryea is probably one of the best
attackers in the format it is faster
than Charizard its ability hustle
decreases its accuracy but increases his
attack power in Dynomax the moves don't
miss so you get the attack bonus without
the accuracy liability and then it also
has a life orb which increases attack
pile their power further and just chips
away at the Pokemon HP it has a really
high defense and really low special
defense so one of the moves is max quake
which increases special defense on your
side of the field so um that's a pretty
big one I would say you should name it
Durant Durant Durant Durant capital is
trapping the Pokemon in here so I could
switch out a Pokemon that could threaten
real a boon for example and I used max
skills back to increase defense I think
because real boom is an attacker Darren
says podcast is dope
they also say oh my god pokemons math I
just press a so this is interesting
because you mostly don't see seismitoad
on a team that can't
run rain the only pokemon in the pokédex
right now that has access to rain as an
ability the drizzle ability is pelipper
so you often see seismitoad with
pelipper so I'm interested to see what
this seismitoad does and then Gotha tell
has helping hand which just increases
Durant's attack further the durant is
just like one of those pokemon that can
get one hit chaos pretty easily oh man
although i wasn't expecting that cuz
seismitoad he is typically a bulkier
pokemon
[Applause]
oh I'm a little scared sorry I lost I
keep messing up here hold on no good I'm
doing great at this so grassy terrain is
nice because it will heal like I think
it's 1/8 of the HP or no 1/16 of the HP
per turn
I'm just gonna not look at that anymore
keep messing it up
also if you if you are watching this
stream and you're really interested in
competitive pokemon but you're kind of
afraid where to start or how it's gonna
work
Kali and I actually working on a video
series right now that goes over all of
that stuff and the first episode is done
and it's like 8 minutes long so it goes
over all the stats in under 8 minutes
which is or how stats working on are a
[ __ ] 8 minutes which is pretty
impressive but look for that end of the
month because we're gonna have I think
three episodes right now that are gonna
roll out day after day and so far the
first one is very good the script for
the second one is coming along very well
and there's numbers too lots of numbers
right in the second one I'm sure a lot
of numbers but I I try to make the stats
explanation as beginner friendly as
possible so it doesn't go into like the
really hard math of how effort values
work which is a little simple it's
simple when you know how it works but
it's a little intimidating when you
don't yeah ah you're really happy I did
that actually really quickly Gotha tell
would be weak to max darkness I switched
in arc and I and because arcanine
threatens both guerrilla boom and core
of night and now that seismitoad is out
of the picture I don't have to worry
about seismitoad knocking out Arcanine
and max darkness did nothing to our
cation with the intimidate up anyway
sorry
oh yeah that that's a good call that
promo for that sweet video series yeah
explaining competitive Pokemon look out
for it I'm definitely trying to make it
as accessible as possible yeah I mean
you watched it John Luke you watched the
first episode it made sense right it
made sense to me
also he'd shout out to Jake for doing
some really nice graphics I think I try
it
assists thank you helpful it is okay
this is yeah Jake's graphics are awesome
and there's some cool sound effects and
stuff yeah look for that I was worried
that was not gonna hit I'm glad that hit
korbinites pretty bulky nope dang
so rocks light I was hoping if I didn't
knock out Korff night would cause
carbonite to flinch real a boom can't
flinch
flinch while it's dinah maxed Durant
looks so tiny next arcanine and really
boom as well of course say like that you
took the smaller Pokemon and made it
though the big boy well now you'll
probably see it missing because so
Durant's gonna be first but it might
miss because of the hustle ability so
arcanine is just good support oh you
probably already explained it cuz
Dynomax you can't miss which is that
that's why thank you so when you're
using Durant you kind of want to
prioritize Diana maxing it okay that's
interesting because last time we did
this which was when the game came out we
were both of us yeah we were trying to
figure out how Dyna maxing would fit in
like and like what the strategy round
dynamics thing would be and it's kind of
cool that there has been like you know
more that stuff is surfaced I'm learning
a lot more the more I battle about ways
to use Dynomax you can use Dynomax
defensively it basically the the thing
that Dynomax does is it increases HP
pretty drastically good game edward
thanks Edward alright if you're in the
chat and you want about Callie we have
the code 0 to 79 I'm gonna be taking
lead cards as well I'm gonna quit and
give somebody else a chance to battle
and again I'm using I'm gonna keep
forgetting the person's name
I mean I'm using a rental team which I
think I can I can show off the code if
you all want to use this team I can show
that off later as well but I'm really
liking this team it definitely fits my
play style a lot better you say it seems
like there are a lot of good kind of
layers to the strategy involved on how
to use all the Pokemon and
yeah I'm just like not I'm not a hyper
offense kind of person mmm
so I am gonna say the person's name
again Luke Amir PB l UK ami r PB on
Twitter this is 13 all right do you guys
see the so you know and I forget where
it is was it turf field whether you've
there's the giant Pokemon in the hill
that you can see but did you see that it
looks more like Giganta max toxicity
more than anything else and people are
like ooh this is the this is that was
the Pokemon over there because if you
look at if you compare the tail it's
like the same it's got that weird
antenna fan yeah so a lot of people are
like what if this is the space pokemon
its talks tricity all along we're
actually trained I would you can rent
teams right yeah I breed Pokemon I
really like green cook mutton but I've
rented this team just because I think
it's best to get practice with a team
that a really knowledgeable is made
before you start making your own team so
you get a sense of the flow of battles
for me it was really important
understanding the role of Dynomax in
this format yeah so yeah
Errol says they also have a bolt ined
named barky Allen cute that's cute
Brennan says the new studio setup looks
awesome glad you guys have more people
on the stream yeah it's a really good
setup I like having more people and I
also like how comfortable more comedies
it's a good coach I don't mind that
other stream room but it gets hot in
there so we're just waiting on this
person to to pick a team I imagine they
might be individually selecting rather
than having a premade team which is what
can take okay that's fine yeah well like
I was saying
dynamaxx increases HP that's the only
thing it increases and then the max
moves have a higher base damage so you
can use it defensively to patch up
pokemons HP like Barracuda is a Pokemon
that has pretty low HP but really high
damage
output so if you Dynomax tit that
increases its HP and and kind of fixes
that problem temporarily that's a
Pokemon you just like a glass cannon
that you just want to like hit as hard
as you can
so Durant is is it's not exactly the
same but I like to add a mixing die
Durant because I can just get those
knockouts and then it served its purpose
and then I can rotate in arcanine and
sylveon to finish the job okay let's see
oh god chars Charizard really just oh
thanks reading out Darren yeah
appreciate you checking in on the stream
welcome for the chat oh man
I'm late for the weekend guys I'm about
you big same it's been a week are all of
you seeing Sonic tomorrow no you guys
are gone I I didn't think I'd be in town
for it okay so I said I couldn't go
turns out I am but that's okay I don't
need to sorry
very excited for that though yeah I'm
going see you there
I gotta pry myself away from pso2 though
that's the real issue you who are like
I'm gonna try not to talk yep sonic
second second
PSO this weekend plans hard it's a very
good card mmm
Marcus says hey guys like your podcast
Thank You Marcus thank you
speak guy crash does I want to fight
next you can fight next just get
yourself ready and have the code we're
gonna use and if we're just going by the
honor system so if you have like oh this
this intimidate is gonna help me so much
both of these are physical attackers um
yeah we're just like you know if you've
already battled please leave room for
other people to battle mm-hmm so on this
melodic muddy water is used as a spread
move and therefore it can hit an
opposing Pokemon with gastro dawn on the
field gastro dawn
[Music]
has the ability storm drain which
redirects water attacks normally so if
there's a single target water attack
it'll just go into gastro Don but if I
wanted to hit cinder ace I could do that
with Oh God
he's gone I could do that with muddy
water so that I think is that the reason
muddy water is on this one
I like that you have sin erase just
being like I'm out are can die and I'm
gonna use will oeis to further [ __ ]
wait
Oh was it fake outed what happened I
think you missed it missed okay this is
what I get for not paying attention um
I'm gonna do it again because I really
want a crippled Como's attack burns hat
I think they have attack I don't know
the exact calculation they're fit
paralysis have speed so I think burn has
attack the sound the mixing is earrings
so I'm hoping that this really impacts
the efficacy of this Dynomax turn in
melodicas is a super bulky Pokemon so
I'm not super worried about it taking a
text from cinder ace sails a whole lot
of buildup is it kind of not much
happening
so this is going to create a stain a
Santorum archetype is also very bulky
and I have used intimidate which dropped
the tack of stage and then it burned it
so it's damaged outputs really gonna be
reduced and then further melodic has a
citrus berry which will activate when
its HP gets below half and then it has
recover as well so the melodic staying
power is really really good
the thing about targeting Dynomax
pokemon is they can use max guard I
don't know if come oh oh I have a
feeling this Como as a salt vest don't
you don't really battle a lot I don't
want to use muddy water because that's
embrace my just bounce
[Music]
[Music]
Chesson the chat says y'all are chill to
watch while finishing my pokedex I mean
heck yeah
how close is how close to you she's
still watching Josh says who plays
Pokemon in dock mode Lowell well you do
when you want to stream it I did I I've
actually found myself playing this one
docked more than I thought I would yeah
is weird a fair amount well so me my
girlfriend would play dock because we
would be like watching each other and
like playing with each other so so max
knuckle is gonna increase attack that
undoes the effect of the intimidate
however sylveon is going to have a super
effective hyper voice and it this como
so josh is just messing with us oh good
no word it's hard to it's hard to tell
when people are messing with us and
they're mean though yeah right like it's
that's always the problem with chat is
gonna be oh no ok that triggered the
it's called a pinch Berry berries that
activate when you reach a certain health
point oh no I didn't anticipate thing
it's not too bad it's not I'm and a not
to worry about defense both Pokemon are
special attackers
that's not gonna be effective on the
cinder ace but it is gonna get rid of
the como so just says they are 50 away
from completing the Pokedex
those speakers can't handle it yeah and
that'll increase
sylveon special attack so this'll be
honest interesting like I said I didn't
build this team it has quick attack and
I think the purpose of that is because
of sylveon civility pixelate quick
attack I'll be a fairy type move you can
quick attack your own Tyranitar and
trigger tyrannosaurs weakness policy
weakness policy as an item when a
pokemons hit with a super effective
attack it increases its attack and
special attack buys two stages so it
doubles Terrans hearts attack doing that
it's a it's a really interesting
strategy when people hit their own
pokemon this is all wild because my
usual things like ah they're fire type
I'm gonna use a water tank yeah I did it
get select dark and psychic and poison
and I'm like I don't know what's good
against what yeah to remember some of
those now that this cinder ace I know
that it carries bounce which takes two
turns oh it's not gonna use it but I was
going to use that as like I have a free
turn to recover but I'm glad I recovered
Joshua says love watching this do not
think I love the new Pokemon but I do
you guys are helpful with the info and
awesome Pokemon videos so far after
release there you go yeah thank you if
you're interested in competitive as we
mentioned earlier Jake and Kelly have a
competitive Pokemon guides coming out
hopefully end of the month
hopefully around Pokemon Day that was
the day that red and green first
released in Japan and yesterday was
Mewtwo's birthday that's true yes I have
a question about that because so amici's
supposed to be like a clone but then
that image that was going around was
like you gave birth yesterday and I was
like that's not exactly how that works
somehow mmm I think it's just like
old pokemon they didn't really know what
to do they were just like they hadn't
really established the lore quite yet so
Charizard as a special attacker I'm just
gonna yawn and place leaf but I chars
arse often dinah maxed so I don't have
to worry about that because of the Jango
some wants to know is the weakness
policy of the same thing as a justified
Lucario it's a similar concept so just
to fight Lucario for people who don't
know is justified increases a pokémon's
attack when it's hit by a dark-type move
so what people will do is use a move
called speed up yeah which attacks for
the number of Pokemon that you have in
your party so it'll hit 4 times you use
it on a whimsicott which is ono
whimsicott does not have a strong attack
so you're not going to really damage
your Lucario much by doing that but
it'll hit 4 times which means you'll
increase attack for stages which
quadruples it so or yeah yes
no the the numbers are hard it'll
increase it by 200% so it's a really
powerful strategies
it's a crease increase your Lucario's
attack right at the gate we've this
policy attacking your own pokemon is a
similar concept but it's only two stages
instead of four Brennan says do you
think a new Pokemon DLC character will
be coming to smash bros ultimate I feel
very confident that they'll do a a new
Pokemon yep it'll be cinder s you know
what it first came out I really didn't
like Rilla boom but I've been warming up
to laboum I think he might be my
favorite of the three I think I think it
might have the most solid I don't
appealing look to me through all of
their evolutions I really like the
middle one a lot I like like just
jumping and pulling things out of his
hair like when we get with hidden
ability it'll be super powerful really
booms hidden ability is grassy surge
which triggers grassy terrain which is
really powerful ability and I think it
has super-high attack so I think it'll
be really popular kind of like when in
sinner or became popular when it's
hidden ability intimidate was available
you get that usually through your
special distribution it's not available
in the game right now alright a good
game we're hot yeah all right so I saw a
couple people in the chat were looking
for a game so I just have to we're set
it up again so up best of luck getting
into this we're gonna do link battle
link code zero two seven nine a Nintendo
main when we said new Pokemon we were
referring to like DLC characters for
smash yeah we were referring to the next
fighter past six characters coming in it
yeah Marcus says it's a non Pokemon play
this games knee was a bit overwhelming
for new players I mean just really not
it's actually the most accessible yeah
my girlfriend this was her first Pokemon
and she actually had like a really good
time with it there's definitely some
things that like if you really really
want to get into it like there's that
depth that you might need like about you
don't need to know to play yeah yeah you
can just play the game casually and have
a good time like you can get through
most battle
just by mashing a se Aiye as a person
who just does the water beats fire like
I can I can cruise through it and be
fine although I'll say come in a long
time I really enjoyed some of the later
gym battles in this one I feel like they
go yeah way more interesting and I like
click Rehan in particular I remember
thinking it was pretty cool double
battles which is what is the my
preferred competitive format there are
people who play competitive singles it's
just not my and while you could still
brute force that fight you can tell
through like kind of the dialog in the
matchups they're trying to at least
introduce you to the concept of double
battles like two pokemon that and we're
here together together and so they're
sort of like seating that idea of
competitive in the story without being
too overbearing which i think is a
really smart way to do that yeah and so
what we're hoping to do with the
competitive like introduction to
competitive series is just make it more
accessible
oh no curse Jolla scary so Joe but my
boy cram rats in there that's all I want
Nick or better see cram rip front Center
I want him over everything what am I
going to do
super mandible classes they just caught
a Giga max toxicity where tux nicety tux
tricity age again tomato I don't know
what I'm gonna do honestly
hmmm this is probably not the right way
to do this
[Music]
some like triple down music in this game
is very good that's really good
they put out a soundtrack I know they've
been doing that for a couple of the last
Pokemon don't think so not yet I really
like that and then x and y as well I
remember because X&Y soundtrack slaps
and I remember being really excited cuz
I was like whoa they're like selling it
on the iTunes Store and then you load it
on your iPod
yeah I loaded on my iPod this Eurobeat
oh I was just doing random music I love
it hmm okay
that's what I'm gonna do
actually actually don't think I've heard
the song before and this is taking me
places oh man this is the witnesses play
I know China I wanna see maybe it's like
rival against your rival I'm really bad
what's his name's bead bead because oh
but yeah babe whatever their name babe
the one that sucks
yeah
I feel bad because I just don't remember
it I feel like I should remember I
really appreciate the showing off of the
shiny yeah I don't so I when you see
like an uncommon Pokemon
it gets pretty nerve-racking because I'm
like I don't know what that pokemons
going to do so Fievel being a dark-type
is gonna threaten my Gotha tell so I
wanted to get that off of the field as
quickly as possible whereas Santa Conda
I can pretty easily get rid of with
Milotic yeah a lot of people are saying
it's beads song I am not the person to
ask about what songs are from what
except for the battle tower music which
is Toby Fox's smile yeah
we'll see if we get that one yeah there
has been that's the streams been made
this is all I needed
let's see I I think Santa coin is pretty
slow let's see if paralyze Durant still
out speeds it someone throw out their
SantaCon does a great name for a Pokemon
oh I love how cinematic these feel and
this one like that's it's such a I don't
know if you're doing this to just appeal
to me or what I'm glad that there's an
actual strategy around making Crammer
and this is gonna increase their speed
further when my girlfriend first started
playing she like texted me while I work
and she's like I just made my pit of
gigantic Maxine looks so dumb I love it
okay so I'm not faster than anything so
Gotha tall does have trick room I could
combat this book trick room but after
like Dynomax I don't think my dorrance
gonna be super useful anyway so I'd
rather just do that
goodbye crime rant sorry but if you had
to go out some way you'd have to be the
giant explosion I got to see it that's
that's what matters
bring Kramer an to smash yeah that's
that's the smash it just eats the people
okay this is the thing I am terrified so
I know about this from earlier Howard's
back story no they're like their defense
thing so no so curse Allah has extremely
high special defense I think but if you
hit it with a physical move
[Music]
and it's gonna it has it has the ability
perish body which can cause the it
basically works like perish song it
might cause the pokemon to faint I'm so
scared but valerian corsola you could
get it with you could have it hold evo
light which will increase its both
defenses so defense and special defense
so that's a popular thing in singles not
so much doubles and see if I got hit by
I didn't get hit by Parrish body we have
a s in the chat forum rant
[Applause]
maybe I didn't hear enough the songs
whenever I fought them I'd usually just
kind of like throw them aside and not
have to even think about it okay I had
like one Pokemon that would just one
shot each one of them as they came out
that character is the cockiest loser
oh yeah it's like you've got nothing to
show I've crushed you every single time
and here you are talking up a big game
that one was close but all gets you the
next time for sure out of the four
people of you who is the best of this
game Kali percent well I realize I
pointed but no one can see my I can't do
it no mines easy okay that was targeted
at Milotic um I didn't feel very good at
this game when I was on the ladder last
night let's see those guys for toast
asses hey there GameSpot what did I miss
everything just keeps getting better we
see I think rammer and getting really
big earlier Bruno's dad's here
this might be the best community Friday
as we've had in a while for Joe's dad we
are just playing some hot Pokemon with
people in the chat if you have Pokemon
and you want to play against us you can
absolutely do so we have the low link
code that we have ready to go how's the
time starts to happen to start searching
I wonder how many people match with each
other though while they're searching you
know like
we're bringing people together also you
through the power of Pokemon I really
hope that burritos dad plays Pokemon and
made their character to look like Naruto
and that's like a whole ninja themed
team like I want the bit to get carried
all the way through team yeah
who's you having that shedinja what's
the other like is it Kara blast
what's the gavel here what I'm trying
I'm trying to think of a ninja theme
you're thinking of accelgor yes that
greninja froakie is going to be an N oh
really yeah I was in the data mine oh
cool it's sir Pikachu Nikko said thanks
for the battle our rematch is an option
we're gonna let everyone else try and
like that in but if you're around and
you want to get back in later we're more
than happy to yeah good game all right
sir Pikachu let's do this
I had that profile picture myself for a
while I love the like flippant aviator
hat and goggles it's a good one yeah
sorry I kicked Jake on accident
it's right there it's just one one click
away I just noticed that that uh our
canines level one common thing is like
yeah if you can just evolve the Pokemon
with a stone and it doesn't need to know
any moves you just leave it at one to
talk about
so the whimsicott salsa level one mmm
cuz it'll be out of level 250 doesn't
matter although for me I level them up a
little bit
I end up leveling them up a little bit
anyway because I manually Eevee train
parts of them like I will just go fight
the Pokemon in the wild to e be trained
so they do get levels that way but you
don't need to do that I just I like to
save I like to be economical with the
item for sure I don't like to wait for
the polka jobs because you get to go
polka jobs too
I shot that polka jobs are a thing in
this game Pikachu
alright guys I guess well try and get
someone else another shot oops
nope give me a second
she's too excited we just wanna get
right back into the next fight no
worries zero two seven nine time Jalen
says you guys should do this more often
so yeah I mean specifically Pokemon I
think we kind of have that it's like a
thing on them I don't know just when
nothing else is really relevant this is
one of the ones that I think we like
doing I think good ones a good go to
it's a good go to one all right DJ sure
I I feel like I fought DJ the last time
I do this
DJ Sabo we're getting the run back the
saw was really cute yeah looks like it's
once to hug um I did this on Pokemon
tonight combat
on giantbomb as well Darrell jr. says
hey Kylie it's me hi
oh it's DJ please take trade battle
series to
Emma says has anyone done a Giga max
toxicity raid I haven't done it yet
we've to lined up though we can do them
after this so there's actually a code
you can get right now
with mystery gift if you input the code
punk-rock with a zero for the oh there's
no oh so you'll be fine
you get three high horsepower TRS tox
tricity has a four times weakness to
ground type moves so if you are having
trouble with toxicity raids enter that
mystery gift code and that might help
you I'm also going to bring my I have a
right on with lightning rod that'll just
crippled this tux trace at a so we'll
see okay so this has a corsola okay DJ I
feel like I lost a DJ the last time I
did this so what mm-hmm
let's see how this goes ops to gun did
you end up getting a flame war for I
don't have a flame war about okay I'm
guessing this is a flame war obstacle oh
my god what am I gonna do DJ says you
won last time did I well there we go
well that's good for me DJ's here for
the run back there it is uh Dustin just
says got this for my birthday seems like
a Nintendo online subscription is pretty
helpful I guess if you want to do the
like you probably need it if you if you
want to have like people wandering
around in the max raids I assume right
do you think so I don't know I'm not a
hundred percent but you could certainly
play the game single-player without it I
guess it's just how much you want to do
online battles and potentially like raid
stuff with other people also happy late
birthday depending on when it happens
when you got your game into the song
yeah I love this song you get you can
tell he made it
oh wow yeah you mean this my chrysalis
Oh everything's all red so intense
Oh matches the eyes yeah okay
so boo both shiny
[Applause]
oh it's not magic bounce hmm
what's having magic bounce would be like
I can't taunt pattering okay so the
thing is I have my own trick room so
running tricking right now would could
be difficult let's see I want a very
special offense for sure
so wants to know can actually choose
music hers at random
you can't she's nice again I chose this
I yeah for these battles though right
not throughout the game yeah yeah
I've been doing random just because I
had it set on this song like I should
probably switch it so I don't get sick
of it there so I used to I used to
random now and this stadium look cool
why have we seen this stadium like in
these battles I don't know is this the
rock Jim what is this it's the fire fire
Joe I don't know I could his name for
the old man
[Music]
[Laughter]
Dustin asking about the scheduled
release for the covers they're gonna try
and get that up near the end of the
month hopefully around Pokemon Day
mm-hmm which is on the 27th around those
days all well we'll both tweet about it
I'm sure leading up to it left way now
we've been spending a lot of time on it
I think it's gonna turn out very well
hopefully that's the Bloch edge and a
real good way to not miss any of the
other stuff we do to it's just you know
is this gigantic get to see everything
that happened like that you also don't
miss any of our streams you do every
weekday at 11 a.m. Pacific including
community Fridays every Friday where we
try to play games with you guys
that's my promo I'm done I promise so
you're saying dynamaxx only increases HP
does Giganta max increase more no
Giganta max just changes the move to a G
max man okay
but they only have one GMAX move right
depending on the pokémon yeah so like
that helping hand really helped Oh Anna
was a Korean okay I really didn't want
to get will owest I wanted to get rid of
that hurt corsola and I was lucky in
that targeting because had erine guarded
so protected um sorry was the question
Oh gigantic max moves so gee max moves
are like chars arts for examples called
G max wildfire it's different then that
is an awesome color this is dope DJ your
team owns you looking like an American
Gladiator and now I'm free to target the
Hatter een though because it can't it
you can't really double protect so Julie
axe wildfire basically works like fire
spin and does fire damage rather than
GMAT or max Flair which is just a fire
type movement causes Sun so G max moves
are like or replace the Associated
typing okay
so like you can't have a you can't have
a gigantic X Charizard with max flair
it's gonna be G max wildfire okay
interesting I don't even know what oh
it's a Casper I don't eat that because
the ghost is gone
um the berry that gotta tell us holding
protects it it reduces damage from one
ghost type move but the corsola is out
of the picture so knock your head off
does not worry me it doesn't look like
this is a flame war ops to you either
Emma wants to know how long has Callie
been playing Pokemon in total she seems
like a real pro um thank you I guess
sorry I like his blue tongue I guess um
like in Thoth I mean my my whole life I
guess
but like competitively I've been playing
I've been aware of competitive pokemon
haha the whole team Durant um I've been
aware of competitive Pokemon since X & Y
and then I mostly just bread because
recent years have been using Legendary's
and I wasn't interested in using
legendaries no my worry is that Doral
Adhan has a weakness policy I don't want
to trigger the weakness policy so I like
the Doral Adhan looks like a Wi-Fi
router so yeah I've been playing Pokemon
for a very long time but this is the
first game I've actually felt like I had
the ability to battle I hope I get a
flinch I'm saying once you go
competitive it's really hard to go back
sure is I did get a flinch shoot
this is it for me all the horses Yanks
it's okay you did a good job so
typically I wouldn't run a move I would
do flash cannon on a derp a load on
instead of steel beam because steel beam
does so much recoil damage whereas flash
cannon does not but that certainly did
not do me any favors
super mandible claw yes I believe this
is 44 it is it's bring six pick four so
I have two options here I could snarl to
reduce its the doral Adhan special
attack I think I'm just gonna try to
kill it DJ said they forgot to put back
on flash cannon oh no I mean I wasn't
trying to lecture you in particular do
you have it I'm just you know this is
I'm just talking so the expert Pokemon
commentary no I appreciate you like
bringing all this like insight to like
the various specific intricacies like
its I was really worried because derp a
little has really high defense and low
special defense but my special defense
Pokemon are all gone it's a ton of
one-on-one 1v1 yeah oh I'm a little
worried though because I think obstinate
might be fast no it's not faster I'm
dumb I just show that it's not faster
I'm uh we're gonna be streaming for
about another 40 minutes we usually go
for an hour and a half it's been waiting
the whole fight to say this point just
say that obstacle his ops 2 god now say
knew you would knock them out eventually
good game DJ I really appreciated all
the shinies that was fun yeah I was a
really good fight that was great how
does those tense I really want a shiny
off stance so bad and it was a square
shiny which I think you probably caught
it in the wild correct me if I'm wrong
Rayne Miller says I'm down to battle
people while we wait in queue for Kali
if anyone wants I'm gonna be using the
same code oh there you go okay next up
best of luck to everybody who wants to
battle if you've already battled please
let somebody else battle I'm usually up
for rematches but I want to make sure
everybody who wants battle can 0 2 7 9
double battle DJ says that was an
awesome battle good game and that they
actually bred that Pokemon you bred
thought it was pretty lucky he's the
only square shiny hybrid that I do have
a square shining of a square shiny
Sableye
but I can't use it for anything because
Sableye you need its hidden ability
what's the square shiny the sparkles are
squares oh that's all that is that's
good new it's a new thing okay all the
shiny Snorlax square shiny - oh is it
maybe not I don't think it is Marcus no
Kali has not lost yet killing it I'd be
willing to try another team this is so I
have basically no experience with
weezing zap I have plenty of experience
with this team this is Asian park's
Championship Invitational team but I
really like goth control isn't sitting
there's a lot of good stuff going on
with this one and I think I've seen
something new every fight you've done
with it yeah and I really like it
because like I said at the beginning
it's some of my favorite Pokemon
like a team of my favorite Pokemon that
so uh Gabby Snyder who was a commentator
like a caster for competitive Pokemon I
actually recommended this team to me so
because I was talking to her about how I
I'm like I'm so stressed with team
building cuz the meta is pretty
offensive or offensive I always do that
it's not offensive it does not offend me
it's it's pretty often spoke estándar
ffensive LY I like more defensive
Pokemon um and she was like I think
you'll really like this team so and I am
I'm really liking it yeah so I have a
question and so if you like this team
would you make are you like when you
make your team when you breed your team
are you gonna do something similar or
are you gonna kind of like take this
team and maybe swap some Pokemon out
with ones you might think that work
better or are you gonna no just try to
stick to this I might change up like
some moves or like if I try to recreate
a similar team I might change the Eevee
spreads of things basically when people
Eevee train their Pokemon they are doing
calculations to see like oh if I give it
this many EVs in speed it'll out speed
Charizard specifically and that's the
Polka not Pokemon I'm trying to be
faster then so there's like little
things like that like if so if I find
that I really struggle against her Sola
then I could maybe tailor some of their
training to fit that if if her solo was
a really popular Pokemon but so far I
really liked it I think so I I went on I
found this team on a site called trainer
tower
there's also Victory Road VGC both sites
have like team reports so the person who
made the team does like a full breakdown
of what the team's breeding and training
looks like oh we were just going direct
with this core okay
a spicy maneuver this is like I feel
like this is directly to be like I hate
Durant don't you so we're going to do
something else instead
Brian Miller says I hope I can battle
Kali I just got a new team ready took me
three weeks
know what's Kali streak at four or five
and missus do you guys have a Twitter I
could follow like in each of us I guess
or like at games if you're if you're
interested in like specific Pokemon
stuff should probably follow Cowan
definitely um you can follow me on
twitter at inky doji co i NK why do ji k
ko i do i would like to change it all of
the handles that i want are taken
including at cali which k wants so bad
and they're all taken by people who
don't do eat i can't be a really good
get yeah i like the style of uh i forget
the name of who you're playing but i
like i like their style
yeah Dustin says they love the layout of
the stream thank you
nice
so melodic ability is competitive it is
a an Intimidator
basically if melodic stats are lowered
its special attack goes up so now a lot
it can probably take out these Pokemon
pretty easily
my Tyranitar has been intimidated though
so we'll just go like that I guess
someone says you should do California as
your Twitter handle
[Laughter]
I really wanted thrill Hill so much but
that is also taken by someone who
doesn't tweet man there's nothing worse
than someone taking a good handle and
then just not using it I'm really
putting these people on blast cuz you
can go find their track don't they just
suddenly they're getting a lot of
messages from people saying like give
Cali her Twitter what's happening how
dare you Arcanine is an interesting
unpredictable Pokemon because it can be
specially a offensive or physically so
I'm just betting that this arcanine is a
physical attacker and I use the
intimidate for that reason so this is a
gigantic max Charizard Angie max
wildfire which will cause like a fire
spin effect that old chip damage a
couple turns
but Tyranitar did set up a sandstorm
yeah it is a physical the physical
Arcanine oh no sure it is a pro I love
that was supposed to go into the
Tyranitar Giganta max Charizard yeah
that was a Tyranitar prediction that I'm
very sorry j-ju maestro's i was really
cool I've seen shiny ones organizing
shiny gigantic stars or anything so
Tyranitar introduced the sandstorm which
means that fire type moves are not going
to get a boost this turn or the next
because the sandstorm is still going so
that does help me I am nervous I think
because this chart chart isn't boosted
by anything and hasn't gotten it any
sort of attack boost I think I can
withstand a max overgrowth from this
Charizard so we'll see Emma wants to
know the rest of our Twitter is I'm
atomic psyche been zapped been djenka
and Jake is that jacob' deck deck
everybody else has ones you don't eat a
spell that's me oh well good luck the
fun thing is though if you follow any of
us you'll probably find the other people
yeah that's true and there is an
official GameSpot Twitter as well I
really Bank are GameSpot yeah
I really Bank on people just searching
my name right because I am the only
Callie plaguey there actually I think
there is another one if Facebook is not
lying to me but oh I for volt forced him
out of a okay so dragon polled is also
one that can be physical or special
Dragon Ball has a much higher physical
attack in Special Attack but it's
physical attack move pool is pretty
pitiful which makes it a pretty common
candidate for a special attacker so
we'll see how this one is trained drag
pool should be the next Pokemon to be
put in Spanish I'd be okay with that I'd
be really okay with that muddy water
also has the chance to lower or the
opposing cook wants accuracy that's not
really a common strategy you see I'm
picturing Drago felt like when Sprint's
like goes straight down right down
slides yeah it's it's be would be it's
uh yeah yeah
this grassy trains basically undoing the
sandstorm damage oh yeah yeah
a DJ day says it's cool that she's able
to break all this down yeah people are
really appreciating the commentary I
think it's nice because like I watched
this and I'm like things are happening
but I like yeah I don't really
necessarily understand certain
strategies so having you like break this
stuff down is helping me a lot
I'm trying to like contextualize the
things I'm saying so I'm not just like
oh it has this ability and that's crazy
like I'm trying to explain it but I I'm
sorry if I'm kind of rambling because I
definitely lose track of that was a
lucky hit no thunder has low accuracy
and it's not raining you need that so
that tells me that it's a a special
dragon poop though so have you ever I
don't know I know dota does this when
they stream
they'll have like the normal
commentators and they're just saying
[ __ ] that's like I have no idea what's
going on I don't play dota but then they
have like another commentary track you
can listen to that basic one beginner
one and it's them like very like
carefully explaining how things are
actually work and I'm like I appreciate
this so that was a really good turn
because both of those moves have kind of
low accuracy I think they're both 75%
accurate they're guaranteed they are
increased to 100% accuracy in rain and
it's not raining and both moves hit so
that's a pretty good turn but I still
manage to take out the dragon bolt so
that was a good turn for me to you know
Pokemon were real and I went to a
stadium I'd hate any sandstorm teams
yeah right I would suck Kut into like
the crowd clapping just saying Sam
blowing their faces Oh Samson says Kylie
kinda reminds me of Cynthia from the
Elite Four thank you that is an honor
freddie mercury says hello so a fun fact
about confusion the damage that a
Pokemon takes from confusion is
dependent on the pokémon's attack stat
so you'll often see if you're looking up
how do I want to breed a competitive
pokemon you'll see I reckon
datian four zero attack IVs so uh
basically a the worst possible attack
step that Pokemon could have if it's
special attacker
so confusion does as little damage as
possible it makes sense okay so that's
not good for me because well no I still
have ice beam damn ring Dustin says is
it normal to spent so much money on
clothes in this game yes yes all your
money I have a lot of money in this game
because I spent so much time trying to
get a flame war think about all the new
clothes you bill to buy in the expansion
exactly it's fast as always the real end
game for me at least kind of get those
pants right just gotta get those pants
pants man
jaylen says would you do any single
battle livestreams I don't really have
the best doubles team I don't really
have a singles team or single skipping
Pokemon it's just not not really my
style I actually in Sun and Moon I
really liked battle royale and I had a
battle royale team but yeah I I would
consider it baby but I'm just so
entrenched in doubles and how doubles
works okay so I was a turn a turn early
on getting this Tyranitar out - so
sandstorm because Terry on her rock type
sandstorm increases the special defense
of rock-type pokémon but I don't really
need that anymore
considering corporatize not a special
attacker as soon as that sandstorm
cleared up I my eyes felt better like
I'd been squinting the whole time trying
to like see it's it looks so good look
so good see the sand coming up yeah
someone in the chat made a joke about
like the crowd being like wow coughing
good fight
Marcus's cases temptin been pulling you
away from pokemons no I have only been
playing Pokemon basically since December
I haven't messed with some time at all
but I'm curious I think it's cool that
another game is out that's like very
directly trying to be Pokemon because if
anything I think that just could they
can bring new ideas that could inspire
Pokemon to like mix things up as well so
I know it's like competition just breeds
like better games for everyone yeah I
think the beta a little bit and I
enjoyed the beta I think I'm just
waiting for like I'm one of the people
who just wait for the full game sure I
know especially with like a story it's
not story but like a game like that like
it'd be weird to like do the first three
gyms or whatever and then just stop yeah
and who knows what they might change
kind of stuff we're using a ranked
battle series too well I'm just gonna
reiterate that for people Brennan says I
have to go but thank you guys for the
awesome stream as usual we'll be back
next week thank you thank you for coming
by thanks for hanging out have a good
week ends this is goth control v1g for
m1 I don't know how you would say that
as one word but says oh my god I got in
so that's you were seeing a lot of
cinder ace actually is really my attack
that's sweet turtle boys here what's the
score I think Kylie you've still not
lost is the score mm-hmm it's just a
weekly stream it's my first time
watching so we do weekly community
streams where we play games with you
guys it's not always Pokemon though we
try and get it to a game that's relevant
if there is one but in cases where there
isn't anything relevant we like to have
a couple of staple games that we can
kind of go back to and Pokemon is one of
them yes
Pokemon seems to be pretty popular so
I'm more than happy to keep doing
Pokemon is a really good time
Oh oh man
oh that's real good I got one during a
ranked battle or the person like
position themselves so it looks like
they're kissing ball guy
I love the trainer card just off but I
think that's such a cool addition like
when yeah when the people do like the
scene jean-luc made us like physical
trainer cards - got a mom print it made
like physical ones for you guys so I
didn't want to change my and too much
yeah I kind of want to grab mine so I
can show it on the stream can I do that
Chiron go either one of these Pokemon
could Giganta man you're saying yeah I
don't think you you've Dynomax much oh I
didn't yeah so which instinctively
that's like my first thing I want to do
because I feel like that's what what has
to happen but obviously that's not the
truth I'm just kind of guessing as to
what I want to do here
[Applause]
but now Vic is locked into Appleton and
dread not because of Gotha tells shadow
tag ability
camera this one that one there you go
there it is yes matin front and back
there's thing on the back too I only
kind of regretted the fact that I chose
69 is my trainer number when I when he
printed it out but you know I always did
and then I had to pick something
different so I it was that day I went on
Twitter and like everyone's got 60 yeah
to be fair we had this game early so I
would I would I think it's safe to
assume that I was the first one who put
69 as their as their trainer ID number
or their their number but you know hey I
believe that's that's canonical as far
as I'm concerned I think it'd be really
cool to go to like the like competitive
like Pokemon Championships and then set
up like a booth
that's like come on by and pay me like
ya know and I will make a physical
version of your card that you can like
that would sell like crazy Nintendo
would shut you down shut me down how did
you do it I basically took some
screenshots cut them out through
Photoshop printed them out on some like
really nice glossy paper and then like
laminated them I I love it it was like
such a wonderful surprise
everyone's got the cosmic uryu jacket in
this fight I like a beetle a lot
especially orbitals can - max good it
has a good G max move - potentially okay
I hope I can knock it out though
durant is such a beast [ __ ] wants to
know if you have any shinies on your
team not on this team just because it's
a rental that i alright you know I
didn't breed or train I have a an
Umbreon that's shiny but I could
potentially use it salt with bread and
stuff there are Chinese that I want but
I I haven't been shiny hunting really
because I want to figure out what
Pokemon I wanted a team before I commit
to the Chinese mmm I just really like
Umbreon and I wanted one right
Sampson wants to know if you could be
one Pokemon which would you all be
Snorlax so I could I could sleep all day
I probably be a bird Pokemon just goes
that'd be cool to fly
that's a real tough crush I don't know
maybe like Alakazam because I can move
things with my mind and stuff like that
cool swap if he's pretty rad I'm sorry
Pikachu so everyone loves me oh man
I think it's no relax the answer is a
pretty good one though I don't like the
fact that the whole like besides just
being big and lazy their whole thing is
also just being an inconvenience because
like you're sitting it's true yeah I
don't want to cause anyone problems so
one thing I just want to point out is
that Durant is is countable you could
intimidate Durant you could burn Durant
I've seen whimsicott with support moves
that could lower during its attack that
really crippled my Durant on the ranked
ladder so Durant might see mopey but
there there are ways and so that's part
of team building is thinking about the
meta thinking about what Pokemon people
are using and then taking that into
effect or taking that into account when
you are building a team so if I were to
build a team to counter Durant I would
probably include intimidate and burn and
I think the whimsicott was a really good
one with moves that lower its attack
really screwed me over so this appleton
has really really increased its defense
it flinched so which is lucky for me and
I think I can just wipe it out with
sylveon anyone go so let's see Vic asks
what is helping hand do in the first
place helping increases the power of the
pokemons move that turn okay so you can
use helping hand - I've been using it to
boost dorrance moves to hopefully pick
up my goal is to pick up the one-hit ko
[Applause]
good game Vick yeah I'm really sorry
about Durant the cards so good the card
is so good though all right I think
we're got about 20 more minutes so we
should have time for two more oh yeah
really quickly I'm gonna show you guys
the I'm gonna quit out of this and then
show you the the lead card with bald guy
oh yeah because she's so good
vixx's GG not like I had a chance in the
first place but I got I am in love with
this card anyway yes thank you for
playing I'm really just happy that
people are playing with us yeah heck
yeah no let's do it again
that's all we're here for to have fun so
I'll do a shout-out to the the emblem
for the duo's thing where the poop to
book more like holding hands yeah
they're like we're tough talk we're
together we're friends
I like doing that you say that's one of
my favorite things in the game yeah I
think they should add other like poses
you can do when you spin I think I mean
you can change the length of the spin
and you can change the direction of this
binge and depending on how you do it
that changes the form of alchemy that
you get when you involve it yeah good
fight Anthony already oh we did fight
Anthony already want to look for someone
else
Georgia wanted me but we do want people
to or maybe I won't be able to do this
yeah if we might want to swap out
someone imagine if it's I don't know if
I can do it from now you can't quit I
don't know no I can't run oh hi sorry
I'm navigating this menu we'll see how
it goes
boobs in the chat went up goob hey
Marcus says my son is beat in the eighth
Jim is he near the end of the game so I
can steal his switch yes really close
okay this is a highly offense oriented
team comrade Draco vish I see him
so that the drilling mole is 2% of
Digimon design you can't convince me
otherwise they just stole it from
Digimon do I want to bring my oh no I
don't coop says that the Jacob Dekker
the one and only it is it is I yeah he's
really going hard with this T that's a
scary-looking team I'm being honest it's
it's the official run back happening
right here let's see what the lead is
style still on point okay Sam bleed
shiny sand lead
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so this combination basically Tyranitar
Stan Stream initiates a Sandstrom and
then excadrill has the ability sand rush
which increases its speed in sans the
extra drill is going to move first
mm-hmm
[Music]
do you think they'd never do a digimon
pokemon crossover definitely not at this
point no like maybe there was
potentially the possibility 20 years ago
but definitely not now I kind of maxed
Tyranitar is not what I expected and I
should have willow s2 the Terios are
they're an astounding number of people
who think that a Digimon is gonna make
it a smash and that was one wait what
yeah there's a bunch people who are like
they're a bunch of signs pointing to a
human from digimon making it into I
would want to read those theories I
haven't looked in any of them cuz I
don't know how legitimate they are and I
kind of don't think that there's a
chance this is definitely the end for my
earth name and I did I should have
burned I should've burned Tyranitar the
so this that was actually just such a
bad such a bad choice because taranis
heart has a much higher special defense
then excadrill and it would have been
more beneficial to me to [ __ ] the
Tyrannis hearkens gonna live longer so
that was just a bad call on my part
but excadrill Stowe's goob wants to know
where all the game journalists are who
don't wear glasses
that's what happens when he stared
screens all day for a loan true I mean
I've had classes in high school yeah I
mean like a middle school for me
but I should have had glasses years
before I got them I also played I also
like pretty much stared at my gameboy
for most of my childhood so that
probably did me in I'll never forget
when I realized I needed them like my
mom came down I was like why are you
squinting at the screen like three feet
away from it
I was playing Max Payne 2 trying to do
that or Max Payne one trying to do the
blood platforming bit um mine's when I
kept bothering my friend in math class
to tell me what was on the board I was
like what does that say on the board
he's like you can't read that like now
one thing I want to note is that max
steel spike will increase defense that's
another way to protect yourself against
a physical attacker and I'm hoping that
I won't pick up the the ko but I'm
hopeful or maybe I will okay oh man I'm
really bad at at knowing the
calculations of how much damage a move
is going to do I think that's something
that comes with time and with knowing
what the Pokemon spread is but that that
was my the best pivot I could do after
not really us being the Tyranitar turn
one usually you see the the excadrill
Dynomax I'm so
sorry anyway I guess flashes because I
couldn't read the board in my social
studies class in eighth grade
which by the way that classroom had a
map that was supposed to be of the
contemporary US and it's still the
contemporary world and still had the
Soviet Union on it so Oh classic funding
in California public schools see I I
didn't get glasses till college but I
remembered that semester where I did
because I'd always sit in the back of
the classroom because I was like I yeah
that's what the cool kids said and then
over the course of that semester I just
get closer and closer and closer until
like the last month I was up front and I
still couldn't read anything and I was
like well I hope I get insurance soon
cuz I need some glasses meetings in here
in the office and you'd be like I can't
read any so this is to protect myself
from Drake a vicious fish sheis friend
which will get a strong job ooh strong
jaw is an ability that boosts the power
of biting moves and fishiest rent is
considered a biting though it also
increases in damage a tricky fish moves
first which it won't
but I've increased my defense by two
stages for melodic and Durant by this
stage so I should be able to just
proceed from here I have Sylvia on the
back too
that's where those fossil Pokemon isn't
it it looks like it might be yeah I'm
just gonna even though it's not very
effective I'm gonna use steel spike to
finish boosting my defense it's gone
radically and it's the only joke I got
what yeah yeah it's just so he shouldn't
exist and I love him them I don't think
we have a gender I so if you don't know
the pokemons gender you usually say it
instead of them um that has been
standard since good to know that's been
standard since ha that's a special
attack whereas Draco vish is a physical
attacker um yeah that's been standard
since the beginning of Pokemon is you
just called Pokemon it yeah
Samson yes there's like a 30% chance of
that happening so Simpson says Kylie
should have your own Pokemon channel
professor Kali I actually bought a lab
coat we were going to shoot on-camera
stuff for the competitive Pokemon video
ok good game Anthony all right so Ryan
Miller in the chat has been like talking
of a big game for a while so I'm really
like they claim they've been fighting
other people and have also been
undefeated so they really want to
challenge you so I
okay if everyone else in the chat school
I'd really like for that to happen okay
so our last game so let's for the last
game honor system please let what's the
Ryan Miller Ryan Miller please let Ryan
Miller join because if Ryan Miller is
out here talking smack
I would really like to challenge them
maybe maybe give it a couple seconds
just so the stream can catch up all they
say they're in a battle right now well
is the battle close to being done if
it's not then we'll have to move on and
we'll try and get you next time but
there'll be other times it'll be other
times well there's no way this will be
the last time we do this I'm just gonna
give it I'm just gonna give it a second
um some more on glasses they said they
just started so unfortunately it'll have
to be next time next time um my dad had
to get glasses just to play call of duty
Oh Owen who improved this Kady yeah he
doesn't use it for literally anything he
doesn't even use them to watch TV oh yes
[Laughter]
have you guys seen that vine HUD boy
yeah yeah yeah
hope that their team is just forcing
relaxes it that's legally can't happen
but some somehow someway one Snorlax one
once and really just one
all right fat boy
a gentleman
[Music]
one of what song we're gonna get
sometimes I get the like Ashington Samba
sense a song with like hey I still think
even with the the Toby Fox song my
favorite one is the one where you fight
your rival because it's got a lot of
like old theme throwbacks in it yeah I
just really don't like the era of the
horn music in Pokemon and I which era
was that that was so in not as bad as
that Resident Evil song but is it resin
evil 3:1 music and the first okay Oh fat
boy here has aegislash which scares me
aegislash has a wide guard wide guard
protects the opposing team from multi
target moves which includes my muddy
water
snarl rockslide hyper voice hyper voice
so I am NOT and aegislash often has a
weakness policy so it can be hard to
take down you have to predict when it's
going to attack and switch to its blade
form which is the attacking form and
it's defense is lowered in that form so
I think I'm gonna do this lead and then
I'm gonna have my cleanup crew in the
back I'm enjoying the variety we're
getting different teams for fighting
that's why it's it's good that there's
no legendary is allowed because then it
would just be legendary is right Kelly I
really hate when they allow it Darius
that was you saw so many mirror teams in
that Oh
like it oh that's great
you saw a lot of like Kyogre versus
brown versus Rayquaza teams and I just
was so sick of it he's got to stop pants
on to talk to losers shiny yeah that's
good shiny also be good for smash to be
a good one for smash actually I could I
could see that okay I can see that I get
sad too I just feel like it's gonna have
to be one of the the starters it's like
the safer bet but the starters are
legendary right but I mean I guess like
they put in lucario lucario is just a
like it was a special Pokemon right cuz
didn't the creator of there's some cool
thing about who designed the caria or
something huh right ninja
sorry i was i distracted you i'm sorry
sorry what is it Lucario wasn't it made
by the original like that design was
created by the original creator I don't
I have no idea
remember locario had a movie there you
go
I know that this that was such a bad
turn I'm so upset a lot of design stuff
for greninja came from smash before it
got into Pokemon like oh yeah the water
shuriken was the thing that they made
for smash and they put into Pokemon Week
outs of it i think i mean greg ninja
google greg ninja
I was telling you that golurk is in this
game because it was created by a British
designer okay I did say apparently
Lucario's english voice actor was a same
voice of Goku Oh fun fact apparently
that's why airless named Erol would know
okay I hope this just cuz it's still in
blade form okay thank God that aegislash
was gonna give me so much trouble
and that increases defense but that's
not what I mean
or special defense which is nice because
I was I tried to use steel spike the
first turn when I was trying to Dynomax
because I wanted to increase my defense
against aegislash
in this case I'm glad that I have that
special defense boost because talks
tricity is a special attacker so but
then we have cinder ace
so you know I helping hand Durant is
just unstoppable really so cinder ace is
my bigger threat
[Music]
silently yeah after the stream I'm using
uh Durant from now on so Ken Sugimori
and he's credited for the Sumari is the
artist is best known as the character
designer and art director for Pokemon
franchise and designed the first hundred
fifty-one Pokemon that's what I was
talking about so I think that's a little
bit misleading because Sugimori did the
like watercolor art but there are
multiple designs yeah I'm sure very fair
so I mean I'm not trying to crack you
I'm just explaining it for people I've
been really enjoying there's that one
it's a couple there's like some Twitter
accounts I've kind of like talking about
like older Pokemon designs and like
chain dr. lavas lost Pokemon yeah that's
a great Twitter account I've been really
because I knew that like there's
differences in the spray art compared to
like the original Japanese release in
the American release but I I didn't I
wasn't aware of a lot of those changes
so it's been really cool following that
Twitter con seeing like how they kind of
changed and evolved them over time and
improve the designs I think that's neat
another way you could counter by the way
is you could counter the helping hand
with taunt you could taunt Gotha tell
and then Gotha tell wouldn't be able to
use any supporting moves Tom makes the
Pokemon use only attacking moves so it's
really damaging for support of Pokemon
and it would render Gotha tell kind of
not as helpful
so there's plenty of ways to counter
Durant I really don't want people to
think like during the soapy and right uh
this is really unfair I do want to give
people like tips on how to counter this
book one so I would definitely if you
see this combination I would use taunt
Pokemon that can learn tante include
oxygen grim snarl whimsicott a group
snarling whimsicott both have prankster
which gives them extra priority for
those moves you could intimidate it you
could burn it you I think one thing is a
dragon pulse is gonna be faster than
Durant dragon pool can learn thunder
wave which will slow it down which gives
you more room in the coming turns to
counter it so there's all sorts of
things you could do
[Applause]
I'm glad I recovered from that I was so
so worried after that turn after I
screwed up that turn it's really
annoying because you can click Dynomax
and then if you want to back up it
reverts to not Dynomax and so you have
to reek licked I know I know that's just
something to be aware of - all right
well I think that it's gonna call it
yeah bad boy yeah sorry to everybody
that we didn't get to battle but I
guarantee we'll do this again at some
point oh yeah um let me before we go
away let me show everybody the the team
coat if you want to download this oh yes
called goth control so the way you can
rent teams do you go to battle stadium
in the versus mode you go to rental
teams and then you can manage teams
you're renting or manage teams to share
that's how you upload your own teams so
I'm just going to use this as a good
check it and then you can see the team
so this is a full layout of this
person's team with the download codes
you can rent it yourself and then all
the pokemons held items their abilities
and their moves the only thing it
doesn't include is their nature but you
can do that just by going into the
battle tower and checking their
summaries which is what I do when I rent
a team I check their summaries and then
I go ok so that's what the EB spread is
that's what the nature is and then I can
copy it so that's a cool shortcut a lot
of people do that and kind of take
inspiration from each other's teams so I
hope that this inspires you to play and
doesn't discourage you from playing
because you can defeat the ant that's
all I got
awesome thank you for battling me yeah
good stuff
cool I'm gonna head in the back and get
ready to close this out right oh all
right we'll just sit here would you like
that would you like to close out tall
you been well thank you everyone for
joining us again on this wonderful
Friday
I hope you had a good time because we
certainly did and I want to thank you
guys for for coming on and Callie for
your wonderful Pokemon expertise yeah
undefeated champion wiping the floor
with every yak and Jake also for coming
along and make some jokes
it's a very good time and John Luke for
running back and forth and making sure
the stream works and also hanging out
and doing the thing he does but yeah you
guys want to say end of the month be on
the lookout for this video series if you
know if you enjoyed watching that and
you want to give competitive Pokemon a
stab I mean there are tons of resources
out there but the video we're working on
the videos we're working on should
hopefully like lay everything on the
floor and like make it very clean we're
trying to make it the most accessible
and like compact introduction that's why
the first episode on how stats work is
only eight minutes so just trying to
give you a good foundation yeah I should
have been looking at that camera but
super lost but anyway so yeah I hope
that you look forward to it
yeah that's all I got sweet good times
we'll see you later everyone have a good
weekend
don't be a fool stay at school play
y'all can so please danganronpa play
pokemon seeing pso2
end it John Luke kill it
[Music]
you